The Avengers are assembling yet again.
Speaking with ComicBook.com's Brandon Davis
during Spider-Man: Far From Home's London
press junket, Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige
revealed that Avengers: Endgame is returning
to theaters with extra footage and "a few
surprises."
At the time, Feige noted that he was unaware
if the rerelease had been announced, and seemed
to hint that he wasn't sure how much new footage
would be included.
What he was certain of was the most important
takeaway: Marvel is definitely bringing more
Endgame goodness to cinemas.
Feige shared additional details about the
rerelease in an interview with Screen Rant,
explaining that it isn't an extended cut.
Instead:
"There will be a version going into theaters
with a bit of a marketing push with a few
new things at the end of the movie.
If you stay and watch the movie, after the
credits, there’ll be a deleted scene, a
little tribute, and a few surprises."
What these post-credits surprises could be
is anyone's guess, though we have a few ideas.
Perhaps Marvel finally decided to let the
entire world see the video of Ant-Man franchise
actors Paul Rudd and Michael Peña recapping
the events of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"Here's the deal, just give me the facts,
okay?"
"Only the facts, okay."
"Breathe, focus.
Keep it simple."
"No doubt, no doubt."
Maybe the surprises will be bloopers, or a
clip of Feige sitting down with notoriously
loose-lipped stars Mark Ruffalo and Tom Holland
and giving them a lecture about spoiling movies.
It could even be a special message from the
massive cast thanking Marvel fans for joining
them on the cinematic journey that began back
in 2008.
The "little tribute" that Feige mentioned
is likely one honoring the late Stan Lee,
and there probably won't be a dry eye in the
house after it plays out on screen.
The re-release is scheduled to hit theaters
Friday, June 28, and could be either a one-night-only
engagement or finish its second run in cinemas
by end of day on Sunday, June 30.
Why such a short time in theaters?
Marvel has another movie to roll out just
a few days later: Spider-Man: Far From Home,
the much-anticipated Spidey sequel that serves
as the official conclusion to Phase 3 of the
MCU.
Far From Home debuts Tuesday, July 2 — only
a handful of days after Marvel is putting
Endgame back on the big screen.
Bringing the $2-billion-plus-earning superhero
ensemble to theaters for another round of
showings is one thing, but keeping it there
for an extended period of time is another.
If the Endgame rerelease carried on into the
week of Far From Home's premiere, it could
impact the film's box office performance.
Marvel is a smarter company than that, and
wouldn't risk negatively affecting Far From
Home's success just so Avengers could rake
in some extra cash.
"All right, skedaddle there, young buck!"
"Thank you, Mr. Stark!
Thank you!"
On the topic of big box office bucks, it appears
that Marvel's main motivation for the Avengers:
Endgame rerelease is lifting the numbers a
bit.
Many watched carefully as Endgame inched closer
to making history as the top-earning movie
in history by unseating James Cameron's Avatar,
but fans didn't see that happen before the
film ended its theatrical run.
Though Avengers: Endgame took in $2.743 billion
worldwide, it still sits several million dollars
behind Avatar, which has earned $2.787 billion
globally.
All that stands between Avengers: Endgame
and the title of "Highest Grossing Film in
History" is roughly $44 million.
Endgame made $60 million during Thursday-night
domestic preview screenings alone, so it might
not be that difficult for the movie to rake
in that $44 million or so with a re-release.
Be sure to check back with us soon for an
official update on how long you'll have to
see Avengers: Endgame in theaters again.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.